hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here to announce that I'm going
to be participating in the best fiends
competition it's a new mobile game where
myself
PewDiePie cinnamon toast ken Kouta and
Hoover hack shunova will all be
competing to see you can level the most
in one week's time and I'm gonna need
your help on this because whoever wins
gets to donate $25,000 to the charity of
their choice and I've chosen Cincinnati
Children's Hospital and I fully intend
to win but even if I don't no matter
what an additional $25,000 will still be
donated to malaria and no more for a
total of $50,000 donated to charity it's
gonna be a great cause and it's going to
be a lot of fun but then again I do need
your help to win so there's a link down
in the description below where you can
download the game to your mobile device
and you can help cheer me on give me
advice help me level up in whatever way
you can because I only have a week for
this and I'm dumb I'll play games badly
so I'm gonna need your help please
help me out and help support a great
cause it's a great thing in addition to
the other December events that I've been
having planned and hopefully we're going
to do a lot of good for the world in
this month so thank you again everybody
so much for watching check out the links
in the description below for all the
information and to get the game and as
always I will see you in the next video
you